i
é
por que por que você levantou da cama
hoje a propósito autoconhecimento quem
nunca ouviu falar disso
parece que hoje para ser alguém a gente
tem que ter um propósito e tem que se
conhecer a primeira vez que o
despertador tocou e eu parei pra me
perguntar por que por que ir pra aula
hoje porque tem uma carreira de sucesso
pra que serve tudo isso foi meu
intercâmbio em 2012
de fato ninguém é controlar os meus
horários mas sabe aquela aula que você
fica triste
se você não for pra mim e se dar sobre
existência 'lista era assim entendendo a
base desse conhecimento que disse que
primeiro a gente existe e depois dá um
sentido para a existência que eu comecei
a focar nessa segunda parte
afinal onde encontrar a nossa essência é
exatamente um mês para extrair a
essência de 24 anos de vida esses 30
dias só foram possíveis graças a tudo o
que aconteceu desde o nascimento até o
dia que eu resolvi criar o catálise que
é um programa voltado para ajudar os
jovens a construir em carreiras com
propósito são as escolhas em especial as
mais difíceis como diz augustin os meus
times favoritos que expressam quem
realmente somos e uma delas pelas quais
muitos de nós passam é qual curso que
você vai fazer lá em 2008 eu não tinha
maturidade o auto conhecimento
suficiente para tomar essa decisão
então o que eu fiz uma escolha fácil
deixei outras pessoas escolherem por mim
só que não escolher também é uma escolha
depois intercâmbio fiz um estágio de
verão lá nos estados unidos em recursos
humanos e levei um choque de realidade
o trabalho no estágio era completamente
diferente do que eu tinha vivido na
empresa júnior
passavam a minha chefe ela ia fazer uma
coisa fazia e pronto 0 autonomia e mesmo
muito pouco contato com as pessoas
então voltando um dia eu pensei triste é
como é que eu posso aguentar passar
tanto tempo da minha vida em algo que eu
não vejo sentido e acordar todos os dias
para fazer isso de novo e de novo e de
novo não pensei comigo eu não consigo
tem que existir um lugar onde eu possa
viver enquanto o trabalho
ele não precisa esperar depois do
expediente para poder ser feliz
eu voltei de intercâmbio sebá sabendo
exatamente o que eu não queria mas não
fazem idéia do que eu queria ou de onde
poderia encontrar
fiz algumas entrevistas e passei em duas
empresas uma consultoria e uma ong e aí
como escolher todas as evidências as
pessoas me diziam pra ir pra um lado mas
eu sentia que tinha que pelo outro
na consultoria eu ia ganhar muito mais e
até mil e um benefício 0 que a maior
parte dos meus colegas de universidade
queriam mas eu senti identificação nas
entrevistas na fundação estudar
enxerguei uma possibilidade de trabalhar
dentro de recursos humanos com que eu
mais gostava que era desenvolvimento sem
precisar ser uma área que chamasse rh
as pessoas me achavam louca de me
questionar quando a resposta era tão
óbvia a consultoria é claro até meus
pais achavam isso e foi quando eu
entendi que eu ia precisar tomar essa
decisão sozinha e assumiu os riscos
decidir e deixei para contratar ele só
depois pra quê
no dia seguinte cheguei em casa malte e
mochila das costas já houve como assim
você toma uma decisão dessas sem falar
com a gente eu sei que foi uma decisão
longa e com nada de empatia dos dois
lados
eu também
na época não sabia entender o lado deles
e terminou assim eu no seu lugar não
tomar essa decisão mas quem sabe você
não prova o contrário eu saí de lá né
bancando essa escolha sozinha
vendo que isso era muito difícil mas ao
mesmo tempo sentindo aquele medo será
que eu entrar na fundação estudar e ver
que não era isso e ouvir depois havendo
enchente avisada mas a realidade não foi
essa
exatamente uma semana depois do atentado
foi a primeira vez que eu escrevi o meu
propósito e isso mudou a minha vida
completamente
eu lembro depois de ligado para a
consultoria que tinha feito uma proposta
ao gosto atendeu falou que era uma pena
eu não aceitar e perguntou qualquer
empresa que eu tinha escolhido
eu falei eu ouvi uma frase que me marcou
muito
há ainda está nessa fase
aos poucos fui entendendo que ele quis
dizer com isso
nessa fase ainda é jovem demais a ponto
de acreditar que é possível mudar o
mundo respondendo sim eu continuo nessa
fase até hoje e espero nunca sair dela
tudo que eu vivi até o dia 5 de janeiro
de 2015
junto a uma lista imensa de referências
foi matéria ao longo daquele ano
impactar mais de 650 jovens
só que aí vem a parte interessante
desses 650 10 para entrar nesse desafio
como facilitadores voluntárias e no ano
seguinte mais dez entraram para a lista
e somaram esforços para continuar
impactando cada vez mais pessoas
esses 20 facilitadores tocaram 30
edições do programa que nesse ano
seguinte chegou a pelo menos 1.200
jovens e por aí vai
é muito bom lembrar das mudanças que
aconteciam em apenas três dias teve uma
participante que entrou ela estava com
uma cara mais fechada no começo mas
séria uma cara de desconfiança e no
final ela conversava com todo mundo
sorriu o tempo todo tinha uma expressão
muito mais leve e mais feliz
parecia literalmente outra pessoa quando
a gente faz algo que tem uma razão de
ser
não tem como não se entregar de corpo e
alma
sabe por quê amor e verdade amor porque
a gente se deixa apaixonar por aquilo
que a gente está fazendo e esse amor não
tem nada a ver com o amor romântico dos
filmes é verdade porque tem ali uma
intensidade um jeito tão espontâneo de
agir que quase lembra a nossa infância
quando a gente não precisava se
preocupar com o que os outros vão achar
e simplesmente era quem a gente era já
me disseram que é o tópico percebi algo
como o amor ea verdade mas essa mesma
pessoa me disse que por isso mesmo eu
não deveria desistir de tentar
como diria o escritor eduardo galeano
autopia ela tá lá no horizonte
eu me aproximo dois passos ela se afasta
do espaço por mais que eu caminho eu
jamais alcançarei a quem serve a utopia
serve para isso mesmo para que não deixe
de caminha já parou para pensar no
oposto de amor e verdade amor pra mim se
eu fosse olhar pelo contrário seria medo
as nossas escolhas na vida são movidas
por amor ou por medo
escolhemos fazer a administração ou
psicologia por medo de fechar as portas
ou por confiar no que queremos
escolhemos uma grande multinacional ou
abrir o nosso próprio negócio por medo
de falhar ou pelo amor que temos por um
trabalho com propósito
isso vale nas escolhas mais difíceis e
nas mais cotidianas
a última vez que você fez uma escolha
importante você foi movido por medo ou
por amor e o contrário de verdade e
mentira
pra mim onde não há um autêntico é
verdade há uma falsa versão dela uma
cópia tão bem feita que a gente quase se
confunde com a realidade e é isso que eu
chamo de máscaras
quem nunca usou uma máscara para se
proteger quando a gente toma as nossas
decisões pautadas no medo e não no amor
a gente começa a vestir uma máscara
atrás da outra e nessa confusão de
personagens como saber quem sou eu como
abrir espaço para esse amor e verdade
dentro de nós pode ser conversando
trabalhando ou até mesmo escrevendo um e
mail no último ano assumiu o desafio de
escrever um e meio das pessoas que a
gente ia aprovar ou reprovar no processo
seletivo da tribo que a empresa onde o
trabalho de cara as palavras da
aprovação e reprovação não tem todo um
sentido que eu achei que mais
atrapalhava do que ajudavam porque elas
olham para o mundo a partir de uma
mentalidade fixa de quem é ou não é bom
o suficiente e eu queria como defende a
carol black que é pesquisador e
professor em stanford uma mentalidade
voltada para crescimento
eu queria ser capaz de transmitir esse
amor e verdade nas palavras que as
pessoas fossem ler
do outro lado da tela e eu fiquei muito
feliz quando eu senti isso
ao escrever e vi esse sentimento era
real a ponto de tocar essas pessoas que
responderam agradecendo toda a
humanidade do processo a humanidade essa
que logicamente é muito além daquela
escolha de palavras mas que nem por isso
deixava de estar ali representada o amor
e verdade começa em cada um de nós na
nossa capacidade de amar até os piores
defeitos que enxergamos em nós mesmos e
na coragem de vir
a vida que a gente é viver não é que os
outros esperam o que a gente acha que
deve querer uma das minhas alturas
favoritas abrir e brown diz sempre para
que a gente ouvir e viver a vida com a
coragem de ser quem realmente somos
isso é viver com amor e verdade uma das
pessoas incríveis que participou do
catálise me disse que o principal ponto
de transformação foi sair da sua zona de
conforto
prefiro pensar pelo lado positivo ir
para sua zona de confronto
e é exatamente isso daquelas verdades
que você esconde ali debaixo do tapete
isso é o que a gente tem medo de
confrontar afinal quem quer se
confrontar com a verdade de que não
somos nada perfeitos
aqui entra a nossa coragem de assumir a
verdade já ouviram catálise coisas como
eu sabia que não era direito mas eu não
tinha coragem de falar isso pra ninguém
falei a primeira vez no catar lixo
sempre incomodou saber que muitas vezes
a gente sabe o que quer mas ainda assim
não vai lá e faz
a resposta está no confronto
eu lembro do primeiro dia da primeira
edição de batalhas ver tudo aquilo que
eu imaginava ao vivo ea cores e
reconhecer que não estava perfeito
doeu muito dá vontade de chorar chorei
deu até vontade de desistir mas aí eu
parei
respirei fundo e lembrei do propósito
daquilo tudo
tudo é difícil até se tornar fácil é
claro que vai doer
não vai ser como a gente imaginava que a
ser mas nem por isso quer dizer que não
vai cumprir seu propósito
muitas vezes para relaxar de verdade a
gente precisa de uma massagem que passe
por aquele ponto de tensão que vai doer
mas que também vai passar
foi isso que eu aprendi quando decide
terminar o meu ciclo na fundação estudar
e mergulhar ainda mais fundo no meu
propósito
é verdade me levou até portugal e tem
que dizer pegar de tudo que eu tinha no
brasil para dar esse passo foi muito
difícil eu tive que me jogar de cabeça
num confronto diário de enfrentar as
minhas máscaras e os meus medos e quando
normalmente a gente fala para as pessoas
o quanto para elas que eu moro lá elas
enxergam só a parte incrível de morar na
europa mas essa não é a verdade completa
e que se abrir para enfrentar essas
máscaras esse medo ea incerteza de não
saber se é dar certo se juntarão aquela
voz da mensalidade fixa que diz ser a
será que valeu a pena desistir de tudo o
que você tinha antes e agora vai fazer o
que no primeiro ano lá eu estava
desenvolvendo como nunca mas se alguém
perguntar se porque ou como eu não
conseguiria colocar em palavras
tinha muito mais a ver com essa
maturidade de enfrentar aquilo que
precisava ser superado e ter me colocado
nessa zona de confronto foi o que me
levou ao desconhecido trabalhar amor e
verdade na comunicação eu nunca tinha
imaginado trabalhar com marketing e
comunicação e hoje eu estou à frente
disso na tribo
se tivesse me contado que eu faço a
organização na qual trabalhou as pessoas
incríveis que fazem parte do meu dia a
dia eu teria achado bom demais para ser
verdade mas é assim quando a gente se
abre para o nosso propósito
as coisas parecem influir de modo muito
natural
antes de morar em portugal eu fiz uma
tatuagem que eu decidi de um dia para o
outro
eu sou uma pessoa de detalhes planejada
indecisa e tinha uma idéia de uma outra
tatuagem toda complexa até o jantar que
eu pensei bem é isso
amor e verdade esse símbolo interligados
é o que hoje eu enxergo como o meu
propósito e quando a gente esbarra na
nossa essência as coisas acontecem assim
quase que magicamente se torna um
simples sem perder a profundidade quando
algo é essencial significa que de alguma
forma está presente em tudo
podemos trazer esse amor e verdade para
as nossas relações com quantas pessoas
hoje na sua vida você pode dizer que tem
uma relação com amor e verdade pode ser
a família um amigo namorado namorada uma
pessoa com quem você cruzou na rua
uma das pessoas que participou do
catálise disse pra mim que todos daquela
turma estamos saindo grávidos
achei uma metáfora muito engraçada no
começo eu achava que eu tinha dado vida
aquele programa quando a verdade era
outra
a transformação veio com a contribuição
que cada turma cada erro e aprendizado
trouxeram para me tornar quem eu sou
hoje
e foi então que eu vi que os slides as
falas era o que menos importava
eles não adiantaram nada se não houvesse
conexão ea real conexão só pode surgir
desse lugar de amor e verdade esse é o
tipo de corrente do bem que a gente pode
criar nas nossas relações e das relações
a gente pode estender o amor de verdade
pra tudo pro mundo em que a gente vive
será que a gente trata esse mundo com
amor e verdade está na zona de confronto
de não desistir da minha utopia
reinventou a minha vida e ainda continua
convido vocês a fecharem os olhos e se
imaginar em cada vez mais na sua zona de
confronto
que lugar é esse para se colocar aí você
precisa ter a esperança de acreditar
acreditar em você acreditar que viver
com mais amor e verdade vale muito a
pena
depois
se conhecer se permitir responder à
pergunta qual é a sua verdade hoje e ser
capaz de observar sem jogar sem achar
que um sentimento a idéia é bom ou ruim
por último coragem coragem de dar voz ao
seu coração e então como pode ser o seu
mundo com mais amor e verdade vamos
despertar para isso
obrigada
[Aplausos]